l'italia è oggi anche grandissima
richiesta nuova slime colori challenge i
colori di non ci sono super speciali
perché sono ora è tutto del concorso
video che era verde contro marrone se
non l'avete vista prevederlo dopo questo
video io ho detto che se il pd avrebbe
raggiunto i 20 mila mi piace avremmo
fatto oro contro argento il miglior
aggiunto e 30 per il prossimo video che
conta sebbene a sosa per sapere se
questo video si raggiunge i 35 mila a 30
c con iva sono tantissimi ma sono sicura
che la face per la rete che video faremo
raggiunge i 35 mila mi piace tutto
faremo slime arcobaleno contro galan
[Applauso]
bene mi piace fatemi sentire quanto
siete forti volare in fretta salendo
avremo solo cose o roberto stoppate
argento come sempre alla fine del video
dovrete votare nel sondaggio pasto e
vinco io o se vincevi tale parola
bellezza
stava simpatica raccomando dovete votare
in base ad un flight ma non in base al
neo abitano
magari non io durante questo video ci
sarà la parola segreta del giorno a
grandissima richiesta sto tornando qui
dovete stare attenti correre bene il
video perché ci sarà immesso in video
una parola segreta che se riuscite a
trovare dovete scriverla nei commenti ed
è proprio per questo non ho già un
gemito verificatesi mi pronti pa pa pa
pa fina cornel pochi san valentino è
stato di tutto quello che volete
ok fratin 321 sì che questo 42 35 come
numero di mi piace che arriverà questo
video 5 gradi tre giorni ha preso questo
io ho fatto cadere qualcosa e questo che
penso che sia la fonte non so dove mi è
permesso fare la bella del tutto me
stesso
chiediamo siano di glitter argentati che
andiamo ad unire lo slime vediamo ecco
qua la mia colla dorata che bella
stupenda non poté l'ora di vedere come
sarà lo slime per dorato cromatura che
mescoliamo
bellissimo qualche effetto
io lo vorrei giotti mare così non macina
più bello dorato bellissimo che
fortunata vediamo il tuo come diventa
realtà
mentre vai così più scrivete nei
commenti se preferite loro all argento
di razzia di un argento non si vedono
tanto però però guarda sembrano
dell'esterno e bellissimo in questo giro
sereno era sempre non può le stelline ma
il mio più dorato finora hanno giusto a
chi si che ora dobbiamo tutti venduti 32
via esperienze di aver preso uno shampoo
una lozione vediamo una colla si trova
bene e io che ho preso tesori d'oriente
duccio creme aromatiche al jazz
mitizzata giasprini già avanti e io non
ho paura che questa doccia crema non sia
dorata dentro così a bianca
soprattutto la slide che puzza che ti
adorato altrimenti sarò in svantaggio
perché mi ha detto che ma romatica ti
prego dimmi chi sei d'ora taro bianca
che bologna eque e trasportati giallo
spia dito ma un giorno scaduto allora
vediamo proprio mischiare guiderà la
trasparenza del mio favore capello sta
dando un effetto superbello tra l'altro
sarà dici tu no lo trovi l'ha reso opaco
invece di trasferenza mago va via ma il
suo segmento più accettato con la donna
accetta dell'umbria bene in campo
gianluca talora adesso di girarla sotto
antichissima si è diventato bella
argentato non posso fare di vedergli
attivi saranno bellissimi che stiamo
prendi il treno sono tre non pesare
sempre il solito lentissimo 3 2 ma io ho
pescato una bustina di essere forse
clijster sono bosco perline forse ma
come farà questa strada donati pesaro
d'oriente e mostri piange lei pregio che
cosa c'è da ridere perché magari quello
cioè non so se effettivamente questo era
giallo sbiadito forse quello sarà grigio
sbiadito bianco lo devo aprire aspetta
un mese ho pescato di fuori inserito
anche latina toledo per carrieri tutti
questi piccoli misto notti si staranno
troppo bene
la indorato vediamo come dicono che nel
cuore d'oro è commemorato eccoli qua
permesso di essere così input toso nello
slime abbiamo vediamo accecanti noi
tutti che 5 dopo delle stilistica ma non
aveva la scaduta perché capito
cristologia london chiediamo se il tuo
bagno schiuma sarà il grigio scaduto
bianco profumo grido scaduto che questo
insomma un colore un po strano
effettivamente fa sempre più bianco che
terminato all'olio si è di 10 mila euro
lenta brano un buon profumo e sia almeno
che erano lo slang profumato dai però
non è male la mappa città dopo
dovete che avete tutto a casa
prendi i tre due uno via io penso di
aver pescato dei glitter perché la
boccetta mi sembra quella anche se non
fanno rumore queste clip considera il
pescatore una cosa che ha fatto cadere
otto volte tra appenda glitter attuali e
mi sono mai stato un pigmento oro anche
se è oro scuro ora scuro un'ora
incoraggiate sembra ma per farmi i
capelli si può ma comunque il problema
che un po duro questo oro fini spero che
non mi scarica tutto lo slime ma forse
lo renderà tanto oro 24 carati super
argentato norge cosa dovevo dire sempre
no e che con il pigmento vedete che
molto scuro sui un velo scuriscono
troppo lo slime vediamo scorrere si
scopriranno la modella mites abbati a
queste cose ma sempre terra prenderà
sporchissimo auto slime che ben ma quale
1 questa sempre più deserto libere come
metallizzato e bellissimo e troppo scuro
di sfumature metallizzato e fuori giri
di governo il calo verso gli arresti con
le mandorle intelata o no è troppo scure
che bello il mio cantata bello il bio è
stupendo vediamo un po il tutto per la
penna caretta la farà diventare ancora
più bello è che ami argento ci mettiamo
tutta
adesso giriamo
era acceso su questo è sempre un po
trasparente il mio e proprio ora pure
proprio questa è la parte bella è che il
mio è molto delicato con tutti questi
colori argentati accesi e mica coperture
tutta scuola scurezza ok ho preso un
altra cosa
ho un altro shampoo o no che mi stesse
un segmento se sono dei diritti diamo
però il vento
questo è il nutrito bruttissimo quasi mi
pare finalmente il pigmento mi ha
rovinato la zai manager avevano bello
così ma che adesso devo rovinarlo magari
lo migliora questa è preso un cambio la
pianista raggiunto un foglio perioso un
cazzo il tempera glitter rettorato e
quindi sono proprio curioso di vedere
quanto venderà ancora più dorata che dai
[Applauso]
le mie temperate rata vediamo se riesce
a migliorare bene anche chiara di colore
così lo schieri rotture così pari a dire
che è troppo dura e via umana va bene
riuscirà ancora più brutta guarda lo
staff pm proprio bello ma fino adesso
sembra caramello non è vero che non
possiamo aggiungere a levanto per le
noccioline fatto il caro ma vediamo
investitura come diventa con il big band
emergente devo stare super attento
adesso mi diletto super metallizzato
metti alla banca caripe dettata dal
momento che vuoi da me è abbastanza male
te vale a dire di mettere guarda o si
sta milan ma quasi non si vede ma perché
io sono diventato bravissimo fra
distribuite un po sì ma ancora più bello
guarda per dato proprio la giusta
quantità è ancora più bello adesso si ok
ragazzi penultimo turno quindi siamo
pronti alla fine per di tre leonardi
non mi dire che ho preso un altro big
mathc l'oscurità ancora di più
io penso una cosa che forse mi piace
adattata wow l'inter cioè non sono
restio d'orazi bellissima ma cominciamo
con becco quale diamo quanto dimetterà
grave è bellissimo e adesso si sa è
infatti la parola segreta del giorno è
quindi se avete visto il meglio fino a
qui
scrivetelo nei commenti mi piace
tantissimo è un altro camere d amore
come diventa comunque si è sfuggito lo
staff ha sicuramente avuto tutto già
sappiamo mettiamo
vedremo quanto diventa argento
soprattutto belli questi chili chiediamo
che tutti stupendi sarà difficile
scegliere un vincitore
io sono sicuro in questo è già uno dei
due già super vincitore come dai predoni
ci fai perché medici sono sì mi guarda
non si vede il mio la proprio
equilibrato colore stupendo dai piani
oggi la quantità di glee la giusta
quantità di colorante tutto partì in un
ultimatum
potremmo anche rovinarlo può migliorarlo
ancora di più bella la pratica non mi ha
[Musica]
mai guardato niente potenti a pescara no
però ho capito subito che stasera lo
aveva bendato
io invece ho preso altre glitter allora
oltre al giorno loro vino che c'erano
delle campanellini joe roth e che sono
supercar in ge provo paura che se
l'avesse imprese poi mi sarebbero canta
tutta una volta attivato cose preparate
un altro pigmento dorato un mostro scuro
per fortuna hanno pescato questo va
oltre gridare viva
io invece sono troppo cattiva preso
questo perché vi aiuterà a farlo ancora
più sto bene del mio so perché
perché è bellissimo
basta di certo fa caso questa slide
nuovo bellissimo però heather tu perdi
ma l'ora di vederlo attivo poi pensate
una volta che diventerà trasparente per
la con la trasferite traction fallo di
troppo bello che bello
vediamo se curioso di vedere il tuo caso
anche come di reiterare sollevamento per
argento sottotetto metti metti quando lo
copriva no è finita
e anche più chi è qui dove lo farà più
chiaro
non vedo l'ora di vedere girone che
misura che abbiamo un vincitore ma dai
carri abbiamo mica tv per questo che
dopo la nuova di immaginare come detto
anita immaginare trasparente con tutti
questi colori glitterati per questo
bellissimo progetto va bene chi vincerà
di piede chi vince ok ragazzi arrivato
il momento di attivarli sono troppo
curioso di vederli pronti 32 fede
ecco quali slimer glitterato dorato wow
allora arrivato un pochino pc cosa
perché non volevo attivarlo troppo
guardate che bello oltre ad essere un
colore dorato bellissimo si vedono anche
qui rizzini dorati e tutti i glitter
guardate come brilla uomo stupendo ora
sentiamo un po di simoni
[Musica]
wow anche i suoni falsano fantastici o a
torre davvero perthus line fantastico
vediamo ora quello di vitale argentato
vediamo se vi va
che bello ti sai che abbiamo un
vincitore
guardate ma innanzitutto il colore che è
bellissimo grigio molto platino con
tutti i suoi brillantini all'interno
della felicità ha grinta e argento
grigio argento si può dire no guardate
guardate che sto bene poi attivato
benissimo non si incolla come parte qui
non si incolla come quella della ditta
sentiamo il podio bollicina mi sa che
abbiamo vincitore qui vincitore
indiscusso soprattutto se ogni volta
pensi di essere sempre certo lo re che
cos'è quello che il color vomitino che
hai fatto tu lei è bellissima siamo loro
fianco all'altra
sono bravi stupende propria color
argento si incollano ben tre tanto big
mezzo è diventato bianco bertolino dato
il cento per cento dopo scuro
non è vero di questi brillanti deciso
che si debba ancora si deve ancora
schiarire dimetterà super spaziale
votate fare il sondaggio se vinco io
team ora offre vince vitale si porge con
detto mi raccomando lasciato un bel mi
piace così faremo arcobaleno zac
riccione 4 case lilith con i care per
vedere i nostri altri video anche il
cambio sapere dovrebbe ridare buona
lezione ciao